I actually believe that most people know
that they're passion is and what would
make them happy I believe most people
talk themselves out of it because they
think it's silly or they can't make
money and I keep telling people video
games was not a profession when I was
growing up but most of my friends were
passionate and almost all of them if
they just stayed the course into video
games would have made more money being a
video game podcaster than an executive
at a retail company a lawyer like I
think it's a pretty profound point of
view they just don't want to say that I
want to say because they think they have
to be Beyonce and my point is just sing
and make 53 000 a year and live under 45
000 a year costs but then you're happy
because you're singing welcome to
Stockholm welcome welcome to beautiful
Burns hotel where we're now
um you're the Sweden yes thanks for
calling out just for me just for this I
got the email
so
you know staying on top of the inbox I
heard that once like when you're gonna
it was someone who reached the uh like
one of the founders of Google and
suddenly he got a reply and he asked why
and it was like yeah we were top in my
inbox you know I still do it to this day
in from 2007 to 2011 when I was starting
to gain popularity I replied to every
email yourself myself it was it was just
what I thought was the right thing to do
I was flattered to get them I'm still
flattered to get them somewhere along
the way the math became overwhelming but
it's still something I think fondly of
those you know especially those long
flights catch getting to inbox zero was
like it was kind of like taking a shower
you know and um and to this day random
DMS people in my text messages because I
have a service called community in the
U.S oh that's great uh DMS on Instagram
and and email is really how I do it
communities where you put your phone
number in the bio you can text right
yeah it's amazing it's a really good
platform and it's actually funny I
interviewed uh kabi Lama the world's
second biggest tick tocker and I asked
him how he reached this manager and uh
he watched his manager watch Twitch and
then it was him and hundred others he
sent him 100 DMS and last lastly the
manager responded so I mean it
definitely works you know tenacity
matters you know I think the tact when
you're trying to reach someone matters
as well some people can come off
incredibly entitled can come off
incredibly unsettling but there are many
people who will email or DM or Reach Out
7 12 40 times and I'm incredibly
comfortable with it because I can sense
the tenacity balance it's a humble
hunger versus an anxious expectation
yeah right and so because they come in
both forms it's either very frantic and
almost like you owe them and and they
just think that and then they watch
something like this they're like oh I'll
just email every day but when there's no
soul behind it whereas other times you
can tell that the person's being
thoughtful they understand that you're
you on the other side are trying
you know and and I appreciate that and
and I get excited sometimes when I'm
able to get to it like
many times in the last 15 years
especially last five years as more
demand has come my way I actually get a
sense of enjoyment when I'm like you
know what
this is gonna this is the time I'm gonna
reply to Carol Thompson or Steve Johnson
because like you see them you see them
you see them but you're trying and for
people that are listening or watching
when you have somebody on the other end
who's getting bombarded with demand many
of those individuals actually really
want to do it but for me for example
where it really went awry was I had to
take a step back and say look my family
my own health and well-being and really
the responsibility of the 2000 employees
I have I started realizing six years ago
five years ago I'm like damn it I'm more
accessible
to a person that reaches out to me for
the first time then somebody within my
own organization and and so I've had to
make those adjustments but I still fight
I'm the flight here from New York to
Sweden snuck in a couple email replies
and a couple DMs like I'm believe it or
not that's the biggest thing I miss
about traveling for the last two years
Zoom
I am a program like a robot yeah pure
efficiency I used to reply to people
because I would get up and go to the
bathroom in between meetings in my
office and that's where I would get
certain things done with zoom it's like
there was no Serendipity time the
airport and traveling was when I would
catch up with friends catch up with my
family catch up with like the fans and
the community that got wiped the last
two years and so it's um now that we're
just starting to come out of our shell I
am actually enjoying it I missed it and
I knew I would I've loved so many things
about the new world of you know not
having to fly to Chicago for one meeting
and fly back it's good on your health
all that I'm excited about both I'm a
very big and guy I think most of the
world's problems
most people think the world is about ore
this is right versus that or it's this
or that and I think it's and and so I'm
excited about the digital world and the
physical world and uh and that's how I
think about it
and speaking of flights when you have a
you know it's a long flight from the US
to Europe U.S to Sweden do you stay
connected on the flight or do you get
that six seven hours offline which is
like the only you know there's actually
some videos running around from 2010 11
of me that says my favorite thing in the
world is flights because I'm
disconnected it's like the airplane and
the shower like literally the bathroom
and the airplane and then obviously the
airplane went away and listen it's
pretty awesome to be on the you know I
still think it's one of the coolest
things to have the internet in a plane
like technology is amazing I don't tend
to get disconnected the flight I took
specifically for this trip is my most
challenging flight the 8 P.M New York
flight to London or Sweden or Europe is
a killer for me because it's too early
for me to go to sleep ah I only sneak in
three or four usually I love sleeping a
lot of people see my energy they think
I'm who I am and they're like Gary
doesn't sleep I'm like I sleep a lot
seven eight I sleep very adequately I'm
usually I'm a great sleeper too knock on
wood I don't want to jinx that this
one's the challenging one because you
land and it's the next day have you had
good sleep or long sleep throughout your
career is this something that happened
like my career you know it's funny prior
to sleep I I've always I honestly it's
not even that I'm like thoughtful
or brilliant or smart about it or was
educated the only thing I think I'm
great at is being me I really believe
that I think self-awareness and leaning
and lack of judgment on one's
shortcomings are two incredible
ingredients
sleep falls into that category I just
have always needed to sleep you know I
wasn't functional I'm not functional at
three four five I don't feel great I
don't know why I would do that and I've
always thought people were confused
about time you know the badge of like I
work 18 hours a day I love that but I
also work 18 hours a day
incredibly effectively so my 18 hours
are like some people's month
and so whether I get seven hours of work
in a day because that's the Serendipity
of what's up my life or an hour or 18
and it Ebbs and flows always 10 11 12 I
love working I'm effective and I I've
always you know some of my friends over
the last four or five years when I've
created better Clarity on how I do this
they're like wait a minute I'm I'm out
grinding you Gary I'm going 18 hours a
day I'm like listen I'm I was I'm like
yeah but you watched three hours of
YouTube videos like being effective and
efficient in your time and that's why
I've always been very okay with
Progressive thinking when people thought
I wouldn't you know when they're like oh
four out four four day work week
a lot of my friends the last three four
years like you hate that [__] right I'm
like not necessarily I actually love it
I would love for the world to be off for
three days because then I could get
three days I can get more rest it's what
do you do in those four days yeah but
isn't that affected a lot about this
like FaceTime culture that is you know
a lot it's different in different
countries I guess but like if you're in
my experience from Big corporations is
that you're expected to stay there until
your boss goes and then that can follow
you even if you start your own company
because you feel satisfied in a way if
you just stay there for a long time yeah
and like by the way
we're up with that my dad had a liquor
store we only closed the store I don't
even know what it meant to leave
something that you were doing early yeah
I wasn't in office culture and when I
got when I started being a meeting I'm
like when's the right time to leave you
know like yes I I think that's
absolutely right but this goes back to
the bigger point that I focus on which
is like whether you love me or hate me
whether you love somebody who's got a
different point of view in the world or
hate them and everything in between you
need to figure yourself out
the end like there's people that work
nine to three four days a week there's
people that work 7 A.M to 10 p.m seven
days a week and everything in between
and there's ways to do it well and
there's ways to not do it well all in
between and the question becomes who are
you one of the things that is incredibly
scary for me in my growth of popularity
is I don't want people to Parrot me
I want them to Parrot me in the concept
of fighting for happiness through
self-awareness and then doing things
that fulfill you
but I don't want them to directly copy
me
and I think that that's a big
responsibility that I think anybody that
gains popularity
whatever you're doing works for you
communicate in a way of what the bigger
framework of that is not the
individuality
Gary what's your morning routine and
people ask me that as if that morning
routine would work for them yeah and
then they go to PE successful if they
right I wake up and look at my phone
immediately because I have a global
company and I'm worried that Singapore
had a fire in the building the night
before like I have responsibilities
other people want to meditate for 30
minutes it's be touched technology that
sounds brilliant to me like when people
when my friend's like Gary you got to do
what I do I wake up and then I meditate
for an hour and don't even look at the
phone I'm like that's brilliant for me I
actually release anxiety by looking
quickly and making sure nothing's on
fire because anything that's like bad we
lost a client this person quit like
normal stuff that people think that
isn't like my great strength as an
entrepreneur and a businessman is I
actually don't give a [__] about the
business
let me break it down I love the art of
the game more than the trophies that
come from the game so for me losing a
client is not fun I don't want to but
I'm not crushed because of the revenue
I live within my means oh and now now
all of a sudden my saving money
content's about to do well
I've been putting out all this saving
money content nobody likes it at all I'm
like ugh I have a funny feeling it's
about to become very popular when you
have a lot of responsibilities you have
different Frameworks yeah and so but by
the way and this is very important to
hear and this is I hope helps someone
but if tomorrow I decide I want to
meditate for an hour because I convinced
myself well I could have just slept an
extra hour so what's the difference
because that's logical
then I will and I think too many people
struggle with changing their mind for me
it's one of the things I'm most proud of
I mean speaking of of self-awareness I
think that's such a interesting concept
and uh it totally depends on the context
you're in but what's your advice to
people watching or listening that you
know they really feel they haven't found
themselves and they try to copy these
you know wake up early tips or whatever
it is but it might not fit them like how
do they back out or zoom out the filter
they're in like concern even when you
ask that question is this is why I
struggle with the way we do education in
the world I genuinely believe that we
take very young human beings
and we force them into thinking there's
a structural right way to do things and
conforming to it
right
most people who are like I don't know
that or what I'm doing what it's because
they subconsciously think there's a
right way the right way for every person
listening right now is to take one thing
for me two from this person one from
that two and and it's not taking for
that that is you
there are many things that I hear from
the most successful most happy people I
know and I'm like yep and there's other
things I'm like nope
this this world is struggling to be
comfortable in their own skin I actually
believe here's a wild one I've been
really working on this one in the lab
about to put it out to the world a
little bit I actually believe that most
people know
what their passion is and what would
make them happy
I believe most people talk themselves
out of it because they think it's silly
or they can't make money
and I keep telling people video games
was not a profession when I was growing
up but most of my friends were
passionate and almost all of them if
they just stayed the course into video
games would have made more money the
kids I grew up with would have made more
money
being a video game podcaster
than an executive at a retail company a
lawyer like I think it's a pretty
profound point of view and the reason
I'm still sitting with it I know I just
put it out there and I've subtly put it
out there in the past I really want to
keep working it in my brain observing
reading emails and comments but there's
something there that feels right to me I
think people know
they just don't want to say that I want
to sing
because they think they have to be
Beyonce and my point is just sing and
make 53 000 a year and live under 45 000
a year costs but then you're happy
because you're [__] singing
yes you do not have a private plane but
guess what most of the people I know on
Earth that have a private plane are
miserable yeah
so what the [__] are we talking about
here
right and that is why I'm passionate one
of the struggles I have is my great
passion is to redefine success as being
content and happy
the problem I have with that is I'm
financially successful
I try to remind people but they don't
believe it that when I was doing the
entrepreneur thing in the 80s and 90s
that was bad
bad for you bad for yes it was that it
wasn't going to work out
I'm a loser I'm bad at school right but
I was so about my art
that I had to do it anyway so I've been
a weird way lived
the majority of my first 25 years on
Earth
under the context of I don't care I'm
just gonna do me
later it worked out for me
one because I had the talent but two
it's crazy to take photo you know we're
welcome taking photos entrepreneurs
weren't cool 30 years ago they didn't
have any status in culture like that so
that worked out if you even deem that as
working out I can tell you right now
there's a lot of negative ramifications
that a pure business person like myself
has that comes along with notoriety it's
not all roses I love it
because I love people
but most people don't love people like I
need people
like I love people look what just
happened with us yeah I'm at a very
serious conference I just got off stage
I knew this was in the air you know and
you came up and said hey I'm like if I
don't say yes right now yeah
then I'm not gonna have time to do this
and so he's gonna be disappointed that's
literally what just happened I was like
[__] it let's go we walk through the
[__] rain and we're sitting here
right now
but I do that at scale like I like The
Stranger On The Bus I like like and so
you know I was born for this era
not because I've gifted gab or I'm an
entrepreneur but because I really
genuinely love people do you know you
don't know about the the moment I
started really digging your content was
when I was hearing you really swear a
lot and curse a lot of stage in Sweden
you can curse how much you want there's
no censorship here so just go [__]
nuts if you want I love it I did it yeah
yeah I don't I
but I'm only good as at being me I hit
the scene in the tech business World on
stage in 2006
2007-89 I guess people have told you not
to curse this is a big thing I hit the
scene in 2006 seven stop
there is no
no Nate to do [__] you hate I never
spoken I was 32 years old I didn't even
think about being a personality the wine
show took me to a different place I'm
like what I'm a businessman I'm like
okay let me that was right after the
YouTube show started I do my first talk
I think in 2007 or eight I think 2007
first time on stage it was like I found
my home this is why I push people to try
different things I don't know what my
passion is Gary good spend the next
three years trying stuff take a cooking
class go skiing play board games drink
wine drink bourbon drink Sake eat
strawberries get into sneakers like
you're not going to know unless you try
right so it's a fun advice everyone's so
upset and disappointed they don't know
their passion and I tell them this is
the best day of your life you get to
explore for the next three years just do
a bunch of things and so I found my home
I was like oh my God I'm great at this
like I knew it because I suck at a lot
of stuff you know what I mean I know
when I suck I can't do anything I can't
even rollerblade or skateboard or ice
skate or ski like I know what it feels
like to not be good at something but I
have very good hand-eye coordination so
I'm good at ping pong and darts so I
know good and bad I did the stage and
I'm like I'm good at this and I loved it
and so I start popping off and I'm
getting booked now we're in 2008
something yep 2008 2009 and
I'm getting a lot of emails before I had
anybody represent my speaking saying hey
you should stop cursing nobody will ever
take you serious hey you need to wear a
suit on stage nobody will ever take you
serious and I just remember thinking I
don't want to be taken serious then like
I just don't want to do that I'm okay
with not making more money like everyone
told me Gary you'll make so much more
money speaking if you stop cursing you
fast forward 15 years later now
everyone's casual I mean I don't even I
don't know unless I saw somebody wear a
suit today I was like that's nice like
like you know I actually want to start
wearing suits because I think it's like
a Counter Culture move you know like and
so I'm not joking by the way please do
it I wore a nice suit to the wedding uh
six months ago I'm like this is nice
this feels nice like pocket square
that's the way it was supposed to be I
think you know we were supposed to dress
up it wasn't supposed to be and that's
why I keep pushing the kids and even 50
year olds I'm like you know what what's
supposed to be what's supposed to be
everything that's supposed to be changes
anyway
right Everything Changes Everything
Changes and so you just gotta be you I
sometimes think I totally agree with I
think we all have it in us and I think
when you go to sleep at night a lot of
people you know what it is that you want
you know but for some of those reasons
you're scared you're scared of people's
judgment yeah before you made it before
you made it yeah you're scared of what
people are gonna think man you know I
pound on this people are scared to take
a financial step backwards for their
happiness there's I mean it is almost
unacceptable in almost all societies
around the world I get to travel a lot
to downsize your home
sell your home or apartment and get a
smaller one that is like no no whereas
for me
I've loved the last 20 years of my
career where I do things and then do
less versions of them because I need to
save money for something
it's a very real thing for me people are
worried about what people perceive you
had Alexis now you have a Toyota that's
a problem it's it's down whereas for me
if we can ever eliminate that stigma in
society we will have a much happier
world because then people will do that
save dollars to be able to go after
their dream I can't be a singer and do
open mics and not make money I've got to
keep being this corporate executive well
you don't have to if you can downsize
but then imagine people with families
I have incredible empathy if you're a
mother or father and you're the
breadwinner to the organization and you
come home and now you're taking to and
now that your kids have to share a room
who wants to come home and see their
seven and four-year-old go from their
own rooms in a nice backyard and we're
going to move to a neighborhood that
might be not as nice no backyard and
you're sharing a room that is very
challenging the problem is I think if
someone is living unhappy much bigger
challenges are in front resentment
unhappiness alcoholism escapism in all
sorts of different ways that tend to
lead to problems you must get a lot of
emails though from people who have tried
this like gotten over you know if you
are you have this job and you're having
this career progression in the latter
but suddenly they take the step out I
guess you get those emails too with
people are thanking you for inspiring
them to do that like what do they say
the people that actually downsize their
homes let me give you one that will
surprise everybody you know which email
is most important of all those
the one that failed on trying to do the
other thing and email me and thank me
because they will never wonder what if
that's not that's when I you know watch
this see it
yeah that that is when I knew I had
something
when I was doing it and doing it see
this is what's why I read my emails
I talk about things differently because
I have a different communication style
but I talk about different things
because I read my messages um
because I need to synthesize it yeah I
can get data my team can make it but if
my team presents it to me they've looked
at it first and vanillaed it down I need
to see it if you would estimate how many
messages you'd get in a I don't know a
week or whatever like what are we
talking about I must have like
skyrocketed oh it's
absurd I probably get 5 000 messages a
day
between DMS on social
email out of those 4 500 a podcast
requests yeah yeah I get a lot of
podcast requests that's very true going
back to bring value to everybody when I
started seeing hundreds over the course
of a year not every day two a day one a
day five a day one every three days
just want to thank you you read
I was this I took this jump I'd opened a
restaurant for two years I want you to
know and you and you know when I'm
reading it I'm a bad reader too I think
I just want you to know I'm about to
hear like it's a success I just want you
to know we shut down the restaurant
yesterday
and I just want to tell you that I'm so
happy I experienced it and something
it's funny stuff I realized it wasn't as
much as what I wanted or I'm just glad I
did it for a year and I got it out of my
system or it made me realize I actually
love law I love that one yeah it made me
realize I loved being a doctor
I thought I wanted to be an artist but
after two years of not being a doctor
and doing this artist thing I can't wait
to go back to my practice and I'm like
this is awesome the grass wasn't Greener
the grass wasn't Greener or you
appreciated something when you were away
from it because you took it for granted
and so we just aren't curious enough we
don't explore enough we don't draw
Outside the Lines enough as humans I
always have all those things and I'm
very grateful for the fact that I live
in a time where I can use modern
technology to get out the things that I
believe in and that it's caught a lot of
people's attention you kind of pioneered
the long-form content where it was
chopped up to smaller pieces how do you
you know I really admire you you're on
your intuition and your vision how do
you see this extrapolate into the future
like we're all going to become creators
if you're a lawyer today is that like
what can they gain from you know clients
it just depends what you want for me
what I love about it content creation is
self less and selfish behaviors in one
format meaning
those emails have like thank you or like
you've seen some of the stuff like
you've saved my life I mean that's
[__] crazy
CR I don't even know how to explain it
to you I don't know how to explain it to
anybody who's listening right now what
it feels like to have someone look you
in the eyes with tears in her eyes and
said that they were going to take their
life and one video you made made them
stop they went into rehab this happened
their brother did this for them and now
they're alive and they want to thank you
and that happens to me abruptly in an
airport or a and I always tell my mom or
dad because that's who I'll usually talk
to about it when I catch up with them or
when it happens I'll call them because
in a lot of ways everything I am for me
is just a byproduct of them
so like it's really funny then uh for
people out there listening and I know
you have some of these listeners who are
getting success let me give you one that
will really help you a lot and it may
not sound like good medicine at first
but I'm telling you
every compliment I get Gary you're the
goat you're the right every one of them
my brain
says
because my mom and dad made me
everything that says you're [__] Gary
you're a snake oil salesman you're a
piece of [__] I take on accountability
it has worked for me it keeps me very
like even keeled
the accolades I don't let get to my head
keeping me humbled
the pushback I accept accountability and
try to understand why they want to push
back which keeps me very grounded and
I'm just right here
and I think most people do the reverse
the compliments
and what do they do you want to hear bad
stuff like well my mom [__] me up
so
anyway that's how I think about it
given the context and the times we're in
crypto markets yes and nfts yes no it's
perfect I mean I'm so pumped about being
on interviews for next six months yeah
I've been waiting for this yeah you know
so it seems like you consume my content
I'd like to you know this is what's
great about having receipts on the
internet I've been making videos for a
full year saying 99 of these projects
are going to zero
and what's happening now and 99 are
going to zero and and so I'm excited
because there was a lot of bad behavior
scams people only in it for the money
which is fine people are allowed to do
that but like
you know money doesn't have soul
you know it just doesn't it just doesn't
and I'm I'm an entrepreneur I'm fine
with money I don't I don't demon I hate
when people are like they made money
they're bad that is that's completely
unacceptable in my opinion as well
however on the flip side
we are now because of the correction the
bear Market in the most fun part because
I've been through this I was there in
2000 when the internet stocks failed and
everyone said the internet was a fad it
was earlier than that because Windows 95
was a real big play into the internet
like so but I only look at the customer
do you understand that every kid under
18 was trained trained on Roblox and
Minecraft and fortnite and Madden like
what do you think they're going to do
with digital assets it's going to go
from Collectibles with a hint of utility
to utility with a hint of collectibility
and that's what this year is going to
force now that people are not going to
pay 50 000 for a pumpkin with a cigar on
it
people can ask what do I get
by owning this nft and once people
understand that sentence what do I get I
know
that many people had the best four-day
weekend that they had three weeks ago in
Minnesota because they owned a v-friend
which gave them a ticket to vcon and
they had their Comic-Con their Coachella
their Mardi Gras
and I'm very proud of that and I think I
will continue to build utility and
now the good stuff will happen so I
think the greed the short-term Behavior
will get fixed
I think there's still a lot of pain in
front I don't think we're at the bottom
because I think the global economy is in
deep [__] like inflation's real like
there's so I think there's some more
shaking out to do
um and then I think in the next five
years we will see profound Technologies
built on top of the consumer blockchain
and I will clip this video in nine years
and you'll smile and be like that's you
know and I'll when it's clear to the
whole world that the blockchain is as
important as the internet then we we own
nfts to do things do you see
similarities in the early days of social
media because they were really early
into that very much the only difference
was there wasn't Greed from everybody
there was greed and VCS and startup
people
there was hundreds of social networks
that went out of business
hundreds so I've met a guy who uh sold
his company to Facebook and I was like
what what did you do oh I I took
Facebook and I made it red instead of
blue
yeah that was it there was there there
was there was things like bibo AOL
bought bibo for 850 million dollars
like so you know there's always that
stuff it happens but I think
you know this is a very exciting time
where I think the real stuff's next
okay
this is a question that I love is there
something that you believe
that most others do not at all yes I
believe nice guys finished first
in business
and the world doesn't
most people don't think there's a place
like they think you get run over
I think people that say who and by the
way here come the comments already Gary
that's [__] I'm a nice I actually
love talking to people who claim that
I'm wrong when I talk to them for like
seven minutes eight there's only two
things that happen nine out of ten of
them have this one of two situations one
they are so afraid of conflict
with you with no in their scenarios
they're scared they don't have the
ability to be candorous
thus they get walked all over but it's
really on them because of their fear of
being candorous
they're not authentic
and they fear conflict
and they can't be candorous that is not
the other person's fault
and believe it or not I'm great as a
public figure with Candor but I've had
my struggles operating in in my life or
number two they're manipulating
there's a lot of people who love to say
they're not many people try to do nice
things for me
Carry Out Gary I see you're flying to
Sweden I'd love to pick you up at the
airport and drive you to the hotel I'm
like that's very very nice but what I
know what that email is actually saying
is I'd like you to pitch I'd like to
pitch you my business or ask you for
advice for 45 minutes after eight hour
flight on the way to you know and and
I'm very flattered but let's call a
spade a spade that wasn't a kind act
that was an act grounded in I'll do this
because I want to ask you this there's
so many people that will do something
for you with full intent of asking for
something far greater on the other end
that's not kindness that's manipulation
so I tell the nice guys and gals that
don't believe in what I'm saying to
really look inside themselves and
understand are you manipulating to an
outcome you want are you are you lacking
the ability to be candorous thus
rendering the other person to not even
know what's happening because you're
keeping it inside or you actually
feeling finishing glasses as a nice guy
there's all also this part you may be
nice you also might not be talented
like you know and and what is finishing
first and last mean my point of Nice
Guys Finish First is you will feel good
about yourself
I am surrounded because of the career
that I've built for myself with very
successful people in their 60s to 90s
um that generation a high percentage of
them are deeply unhappy and why is that
they burn Bridges
they they compromised their value
systems
they for their success correct money
again I want everybody here I'm trying
to make money I want to buy New York
Jets they're expensive
it's not the money part it's that people
were convinced that money would make
them happy
money's not the problem The Narrative is
the problem
and that's why I'm passionate about
changing the narrative
doing what you love and living within
the means of what that thing pays you
whether it's fifty thousand dollars or
50 million dollars
is the game you know many people make a
million dollars a year very stressed
right now because they overextended
themselves they bought a plane and a and
a house and a second house and a third
house and we're getting hard to get
sneakers and watch right
it's not about how much you make it's
how much you save it's how you manage it
and most importantly your relationship
with it and most importantly your
relationship with your own values and
who you are money is not going to make
you happier it's just a proven fact at
this point we have to stop acting like
it does
when are you going to buy the New York
Jets
you want to reel I'll leave you with a
bomb the realist answer and I've never
said this publicly is next week no I
wish
um you know what's funny I really
believe it's gonna happen which is crazy
because a million things have to happen
besides even the insane wealth creation
which is going to be very hard
I I hope it's as late as possible yeah
because of what's next well listen I
want to win a Super Bowl and all that
like I'm excited to operate but what I
would say is if God came down and she or
he said to me how do you want it I would
say give it to me with 10 years to live
and let me get one Super Bowl in that
window
not because of anything else but because
the process of trying to get them is the
great joy of my professional life
Thrill of the Hunt is so much more fun
than the kill yeah that's what you
always realize when you stand up so real
for me I've been so
so real for me
would you say that you felt like more
happy when you've been in those real
grind moments than in almost any other
it's not even a comparison I actually
struggle with my notoriety I'm in the
point of my career where it's hard for
me to do something
and people and like universally everyone
thinks it's not going to be successful
that's my favorite I love when the
world's against me as a matter of fact
the nft thing's pretty fun I was gonna
be pretty happy these must have had a
lot of that of course but then it was so
successful but now nfts as a macro has
got pressure and I'm like this is good I
like it so yeah all right now I really
have to go see ya
thank you so much
foreign